we begin the day with the question is
the ukrainian military now ready to
strike back against the russians
five months into this war and the
momentum appears to be with russian
forces less than two weeks ago they
captured half of ukraine's eastern
donbass region and attacks on the other
half have increased ever since
ukraine has vowed not to cede another
inch of territory to russia at the same
time ukraine appears to be preparing to
launch an offensive in the south of the
country holding the line in the east and
pushing back the russians down south
is ukraine now equipped with western
weapons to follow through
according to keeve
we will soon find out
bits of this building were still
collapsing when rescue workers pulled
this woman out of the rubble
her apartment in her kiev was raining
dust after russia attacked the city
again with artillery rockets and tanks
many elderly citizens of ukraine have
had to watch their homes crumble
auburn
what have you done there are old people
here and you're doing such bad things to
them you will burn in hello
harkeef's schools have also been hit
hard
officials say more than 180 have been
lost to the war
this one was a boarding school for
children who are visually impaired
russian rockets landed on three
apartment buildings killing several
people
russia continues to claim that it is
only attacking targets of military value
but try telling that to those people
still working through a mountain of
trouble brick by brick
in the hope of finding more survivors
my first guest tonight says ukrainians
who predict a victory against russian
forces sooner rather than later are
living in a fantasy barry posen details
what he calls weak reasoning by ukraine
and the west in his foreign affairs
article entitled ukraine's implausible
theories of victory the fantasy of
russian defeat
and the case for diplomacy mr posen is a
political science professor at mit
professor president it's good to have
you with us tonight you know in the
in the past five months or so i i've
spoken with numerous military analysts
from kiev to london to washington and
they've all said the same thing if we
give ukrainians the weapons that they
need they will win if we don't this will
be a war of attrition
are they wrong on both counts here
well i think if um
the ukrainians are resupplied with
sufficient weapons uh from the west they
can probably continue to defend most of
the rest of their country
with pretty good probability of success
the issue here is can enough weapons be
provided to ukraine and you can ukraine
build enough combat units and combat
power to overcome the russians in the
areas that they've taken so the
situation switches right the ukrainians
will be fighting
outnumbered in an attempt to mount a
counter-offensive to take back real
estate the russians will be defending
this is a very very daunting task
not impossible but very daunting
we know that the united states is
providing the lion's share of weapons to
ukraine the uk contributing the most
among the europeans but that's still
tiny compared to the us and we always
hear that this is superior us technology
on the battlefield that the ukrainians
are receiving is there no significant
advantage for the ukrainians with this
well so far that much of the technology
that's been provided has been in the
form of uh
anti-armor weapons and they've been very
good anti-armor weapons weapons that
allow ukrainians to kill tanks at very
long ranges and by the way the
ukrainians built some excellent weapons
of this kind themselves and i think the
numbers and the densities have made it
very hard for the russians to launch
sort of massive tank attacks uh
supported by infantry without suffering
you know great casualties but this has
forced the russians back into a more
cautious artillery and infantry based
method of attack and they've been very
successful with that ukrainians aren't
getting the long shots so now it's uh
you know it's a bit of an artillery duel
and the west built some good artillery
and good artillery command control and
sensors
but the numbers that the russians have
on the battlefield are really quite
striking and they have plenty of ammo
whether the ammo is good ammo or not is
another question but they have plenty of
it and they're willing to shoot it
and if we leave the battlefield for a
moment
and consider the economic sanctions you
write that that these sanctions are not
going to [ __ ] russia the way
that the west
is anticipating that there are
analysts who would argue that the
sanctions need time
to take effect and that this is only
month five of the the war what do you
say to that
it's hard to argue with it you can
always say that sanctions take time to
take effect the question is trying to
estimate or guesstimate what the
long-term uh you know possibilities are
and you're up against some big facts
with the with the russians it's mostly
an antarctic economy
it's energy independent it has plenty of
arable land it has an industrial base it
has a big and talented population it's a
very large country it has some allies in
the world that are willing to help it
uh in terms of exports and imports
they're selling oil for cash and they're
making good money at it it's very hard
to stop them
so i just don't see that the pressure
that the west can put on them is enough
to get a capitulation i think it might
be enough to get a negotiation it's a
concession that you can use in a
negotiation but i don't think it's
it's it can never put enough pressure on
the russians to make a buckle on this
professor president i noticed too in
your article you write that the russians
are likely to have a high
tolerance for pain
are you implying that ukrainians
tolerance level
is lower than the russians
no i'm not actually implying that at all
i think the ukrainians have been
enormously heroic
they're clearly a very nationalistic
people and so are the russians so you're
basically at some level as the war
deteriorates into a nutrition war and a
war of um economic sanctions and whatnot
it's really which country is willing to
suffer more and which country has the
deeper reserves that allow it to suffer
more and the problem is the russians are
just a bigger country than ukraine
they're a lot bigger country um and uh
they have a bigger economy and a bigger
gdp
and the russians have managed to
hurt ukraine economically in ways
they're quite telling and we haven't
figured out a way around yet in terms of
brain exports so
i i respect the ukrainians and i i think
they
you know they probably as i said in my
piece they probably can hold the
russians to a statement they can hang on
to much of their country because of that
commitment and that heroism but the
russians are also committed as well
putin controls the you know the
communications inside the country
controls the media uh he controls the
elites and he is
he's he's basically told a story to his
people that many seem to accept that
this is a matter of national security
for the russian nation state so we can't
simply assume that the russians know
they're the bad guys and because they
know they're the bad guys they're
somehow going to slink away they don't
know they're the bad guys well you are
recommending a diplomatic resolution to
this conflict and if i'm reading you
correctly you're suggesting maybe we
should try to get both ukraine and
russia
to agree to maybe the pre-february 24th
borders um am i reading you right i'm
not really
you're reading too much optimism into my
piece okay i i believe that going
getting
an actual agreement on those borders
will be extremely hard right um the
ukrainians are going to have to decide
if they want to keep fighting or they
they want to concede some more real
estate now how they concede your pieces
of their territory their national
patrimony is really going to be up to a
negotiating kind of process but i think
we're at a point if my
analysis of these different strategies
is right that going back to the february
borders is probably not going to be a
negotiable proposition if the ukrainians
want those borders back they're going to
have to try and fight for them
and i i don't think they'll succeed
professor barry poston with mit it's
fascinating talking with you professor
posen and please come back because i
have a feeling this war will have some
very long legs on it there'll be
opportunities to talk again thank you
yeah i'll be pleased to speak with you
again but sad that we have to do so
you